officials are announcing new travel
rules due to a new strain of the
coronavirus in england
starting monday anyone flying from the
uk to the u.s
must show they've tested negative for
kova 19 within
72 hours of their departure mola lange
is at mount sinai west a hospital new
york
mola good morning merry christmas and
with those numbers spiking here
how are people at the hospital holding
up this holiday
well good morning jamie merry christmas
to you too you know
mount sinai hospital has come a long way
since the days of
hospitals in new york city being
overwhelmed with covid patients
since new york was the epicenter of the
virus now they say
that they have enough staff and supplies
to get through any potential uptick
in covet cases they might see during
this holiday season
but it's a different story it seems to
be a different story across the country
especially in california where the state
is now reporting
some hospitals have run out of icu beds
los angeles county is the epicenter of
the surge there
accounting for one-third of infections
close to 40
percent of the deaths in the state 40 in
a single county
a new surge of cases is also threatening
the south
it's the southern region six states in
the southern region are now reporting
an uptick in cases there here over the
last week
now federal officials believe that plans
are still on track
to vaccinate 20 million americans by
the end of next week a week from today
though vaccinations are reportedly
happening much slower than anticipated
more than a million people have been
vaccinated across the country
jamie now compare that with the more
than 9 million vaccines
that have already been distributed so
vaccinations happening at a
slower rate jamie light at the end of
the tunnel there mola thank you and
please go get dry